>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Georgette Dorn: I
want to welcome everybody
to this International Poetry
event which is being co-sponsored
by the Poetry and Literature
Center and the Hispanic Division.
And I want to thank Anya Creightney
for helping this wonderful event
and also Talia Guzman Gonzalez.
I would like to ask you all to
turn off your electronic devices
so we don't interfere with
the wonderful happenings.
It is indeed a great please to
introduce today Raúl Zurita,
an outstanding Chilean
poet who began
as an engineer and a mathematician.
Can you hear?
Raúl Zurita began,
right, as an engineer
and became an important poet
at the age of 22 in Chile.
He's written many works, among
them Purgatorio, Anteparaiso,
Canto a Su Amor Desaparecido,
La Vida Nueva, and Zurita.
Altogether, 35 hits in the Library
of Congress catalog, which includes,
of course, anthologies and
mentions in other works.
He's also a very well known artist,
having begun El Colectivo
Acciones de Arte in Chile
to oppose the government of
Augusto Pinochet in Chile.
He has won the Chilean
National Book Award,
Premio Nacional de Literatura de
Chile, the Pablo Neruda Award,
Premio Casa de las Americas,
and also many honorary degrees
from universities in addition
to the Guggenheim Fellowship.
And then with us will be his
translator, Anna Deeny Morales,
a literary critic and translator.
Her translations of Raúl
Zurita's works include Purgatory,
Dreams of Kurosawa, Sky Below, and a
volume of selected poems forthcoming
from Northwestern University.
She is currently a professor
at Georgetown University.
Raúl.
[ Applause ]
>> Raúl Zurita: Muchas
gracias para la invitación.
Muchas gracias a [inaudible].
Creo que vamos a leer
un poema y pues --
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Okay,
so thank you so much
for being here today.
Thank you Georgette Dorn and
Robert Casper, also Anya Creightney
and Talia Guzman Gonzalez for
your efforts in organizing this
and for your invitation
and it's a great pleasure
to have you all join us today.
It's so nice to see so many
familiar faces in the group.
>> Raúl Zurita: Reporte 515.
Me reporto.
Soy estudiante de Ingeniería Civil
de la Universidad Técnica Federico
Santa María.
Valparaíso, Chile.
Tengo 23 años y estoy
en el último curso.
Entren marzo del 67 y han pasado
desde entonces siete años.
Estoy tendido en la parte trasera de
un camión militar que salta con los
baches del camino.
Vamos boca abajo, en filas cruzadas
unas sobre otras como esos lotes de
tablas que se amontonan en las
barracas y siento el peso de los que
han quedado encima mío.
En cada bache nuestros
cuerpos también saltan.
Al amanecer había niebla,
pero ya debe haberse despejado.
El taco de mi zapato está clavado
en la cara de uno de los que están
abajo y el peso de los que tengo
encima hace que se lo entierre
aún más.
Siento que grita, pero
tal vez lo imagino.
Es posible que sea alguien que
conozca, pero también puede que no.
Hace un año se instaló una
constructora soviética que levanta
edificios prefabricados
y quizás trabaja allí.
Imagino sus dientes rotos enterrados
contra su boca y pienso en el
coágulo de sangre resbalándose
sobre el taco de mi zapato.
En un momento sentí que giraba
su cara como si intentara zafarse.
Ya no.
El camión vuelve a saltar y
mientras caigo recuerdo el túnel
que forman las rompientes un
segundo antes de reventarse.
Hay un desierto y me
escucho rebotar en la arena.
El viaje ha terminado.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Check-in 515.
I check in.
I'm a civil engineering student
at Federico Santa María
Tech in Valparaiso, Chile.
I'm 23 and this is my last year.
It's been seven years since
I began in March 1967.
I'm tied up at the back
of a military truck
that jolts each time it
hits a pothole in the road.
We're face-down, crisscrossed,
one on top of the other
like those board fences
stacked up around barracks
and I feel the weight of the
ones that ended up on top of me.
At each pothole, our bodies jolt to.
It was foggy at dawn, but it's
probably cleared up by now.
The heel of my shoe is rammed
up against the face of someone
that ended up below me and the
weight of the ones on top ends
up ramming it in even further.
I feel them scream,
or maybe I imagine it.
Maybe he's someone I
know, or maybe not.
A year ago, a Soviet contractor came
to put up prefabricated buildings
and it could be one of the
people that works there.
I imagine his teeth broken,
digging into his mouth,
and I think of the drop of blood
sliding down the heel of my shoe.
At one point, I felt
him turn his left
like he was trying to shake free.
Not anymore.
The truck jolts again and I
hear myself drop on the sand.
The journey's over.
>> Raúl Zurita: Pastoral.
Chile entero es un desierto.
Sus llanuras se han mudado y
sus ríos están más secos que
las piedras.
No hay un alma que camine por sus
calles y sólo los malos parecieran
estar en todas partes.
Ah sí tan sólo tú me tendieras
tus brazos las rocas se derretirían
al verte.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Pastoral.
Chile is all desert.
Her plains are gone and her
rivers more parched than stones.
Not one soul walks
through her streets
and only the evil seem
to be everywhere.
If you would just hold
your arms out to me,
were they to see the
rocks would fall.
>> Raúl Zurita: Pastoral II.
Los pastos crecían cuando te
encontré acurrucada tiritando de
frío entre los muros.
Entonces te tomé con mis manos
lavé tu cara y ambos temblamos de
alegría cuando te pedí
que te vinieses conmigo.
Porque ya la soledad no era yo te
vi llorar alzando hasta mí tus
párpados quemados.
Así vimos florecer el desierto.
Así escuchamos los pájaros de
nuevo cantar sobre las rocas de los
páramos que quisimos.
Así estuvimos entre los pastos
crecidos y nos hicimos y nos
prometimos para siempre.
Pero tú no cumpliste.
Tú te olvidaste de cuando te
encontré y no eras más que una
esquirla en el camino.
Te olvidaste y tus párpados y tus
piernas se abrieron para otros.
Por otros quemaste tus ojos.
Se secaron los pastos y el desierto
me fue al alma como un hierro al
rojo sentí las pupilas al mirarte
manoseada por tus nuevos amigos.
Nada más que para enfurecerme.
Pero yo te seguí queriendo.
No me olvidé de ti y por todas
partes pregunté si te habían visto
y te encontré de nuevo para
que de nuevo me dejaras.
Todo Chile se volvió sangre
al ver tus fornicaciones.
Pero yo te seguí queriendo y
volveré a buscarte y nuevamente te
abrazaré sobre la tierra reseca
para pedirte otra vez que seas
mi mujer.
Los pastos de Chile
volverán a revivir.
El desierto de Atacama
florecerá de alegría.
Las playas cantarán y bailarán
para cuando avergonzada vuelvas
conmigo para siempre y yo te haya
perdonado todo lo que me has hecho.
Hija de mi patria.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Pastoral II.
The pastures grew when
I found you huddled,
writhing from the cold
between the walls.
Then I took you in.
with my hands, I cleaned your
face and both we trembled of joy
when I asked you to come with me.
Because there was no
more loneliness.
I saw you weep, lifting
your burned eyelids to me.
That's how we saw the desert flower.
That's how we listened
again to the birds sing
above the rocks of
those moors we loved.
That's how we were among the
overgrown pastures and we became one
and promised ourselves forever.
But you broke your promise.
You forgot about when I found you
and you were just a
splinter in the road.
You forgot in your eyes and
legs, they opened for others.
You burned your eyes for others.
The pastures dried up and the desert
was my soul, my pupils red-hot irons
as I watched you felt up by your
new friends just to enrage me.
But I still loved you.
I didn't forget you.
And I asked all over the
place if they'd seen you.
And I found you again just
so you could leave me.
All of Chile turned to blood
seeing you sell yourself,
but I still loved you.
And I will come back to
look for you and once again,
I'll hold you over the parched
earth and ask you to be my wife.
The pastures of Chile
will live once more.
The desert of Atacama will flower
of joy and the beaches will sing
and dance so that when ashamed
you return to me forever
and I will have forgiven
all you've done to me.
Daughter of my country.
>> Raúl Zurita: Josefina Pezolo
rompe llorar afrente de su nieto.
26 de marzo de 1986.
Pena. [Inaudible] Pena y roca
de mi amor [inaudible] castigo.
¿Tú te enamore?
Todo el amor, piedra de mi pasión.
[Inaudible] arco de mis estrellas.
Tu abuela te habla.
[Inaudible] montón de
piedras de que moriste.
Desde el fondo de la tierra te habla
y las palabras muertos [inaudible]
en la boca perdiste para
decirte que nadie en el mundo,
que nadie te quiso como yo, que
nadie te quiso, así como yo.
Italiana [inaudible] tuya, abuela
tuya y de tu hermana, que nadie -
que nunca nadie en el mundo
los amos tanto como yo.
[Inaudible]
Yo te levanto.
Yo te sostendré.
Yo te devuelvo la fe.
Pero dime dónde estás.
Dónde. Si vieron de los países,
pero tú no estabas adentro los
nuevos ni dentro los viejos.
[Inaudible] miles [inaudible],
pero no eran el brillo de sus ojos.
Se vinieron las estaciones del
nuevo mundo, pero tú no estabas.
No estaba la noche
cubriendo los todos.
No estabas tú, mar
de las estrellas.
Ven ahora niño pequeño.
Y no juego más de las escondía.
Te moriste.
Acércate ahora.
Cubrí mi cara y mira.
¿Miro?
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Josefina Pezolo begins to cry
in front of her grandson.
March 26, 1986.
Boulder. [Inaudible]
Boulder and bedrock
of my love [inaudible] una castigo.
¿Tú te enamore?
My love, all of it, solid
stone of my passion.
[Inaudible] Dome of stars.
Your abuela speaks to you.
You are [inaudible].
To you, pile of stones who died.
From the bottom of
earth, she speaks to you
and the dead words crowd my mouth,
perdiste to say to you that no one
in the world, that no one loved you
as I, that no one loved you as I.
Italian by birth, you are abuela
and you are sister's abuela
that no one - that no one ever
in the world loved
you both so much as I.
[Inaudible] I'll lift you up.
I'll hold you.
I'll give you back your faith.
But tell me where you are.
Where you are.
The countries came but you
were not among the old or new.
Thousands of flying ships came,
but they were not the
shine of your eyes.
The stations of the new world
came, but you weren't there.
All things were not
covered over by night.
You were not there,
sea of every star.
Come now lovely little one.
Don't play hide-and-seek anymore.
You died. Come close to me now.
Cover my weep and look.
Do I look?
>> Raúl Zurita: De
Sueño Para Kurosawa.
Sueño 129 para Kurosawa.
Como inmensas pirámides de
vidrio las montañas se tendían
transparentándose mientras el campo
intensamente rojo que llegaba hasta
sus faldeos tenía la consistencia
dudosa de la sangre o del atardecer.
Me di cuenta de que me había
quedado dormido mientras escribía
el guión.
Me ganaba la vida en eso.
Y que la imagen no era seguramente
más que una entre los millones que
se suceden en esos
cabeceos casi instantáneos.
La pantalla del computador se había
ido a negro y al intentar mover el
mouse para reanudar el trabajo
advertí que últimamente los
temblores de mi lado derecho habían
recrudecido y que los dedos se
negaban a obedecerme.
Nevaba.
La deslumbrante blancura hería mis
ojos y el frío hacía que caminara
con torpeza, con pasos muy cortos.
Recordaba haber estado en mi
infancia en ese mismo lugar y que la
nieve me había cegado mientras los
otros niños me llamaban para que
los alcanzara.
De pronto me sorprendió
que nevara en primavera.
Al abrir los ojos vi las montañas
transparentes y más acá,
infinidades de flores rojas
emergiendo de la nieve como si
fueran vísceras sangrantes.
Mis dedos corrían
deslizándose por el teclado.
Entendí tus películas, alcancé
todavía a gritarle a Kurosawa,
entendí tus guiones: hay nieve,
hay un hombre con Parkinson que
acaba de caer sobre la nieve.
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Dream 129 for Kurosawa.
Like immense glass pyramids
they hung, becoming transparent
as the intensely red
countryside that reached the base
of the slope has a certain
consistency of blood or dusk.
I realized that I'd fallen
asleep while writing the script.
That's how I earned a living.
And yet the one image was surely
not one among millions that happen
at those almost instantaneous
moments of nodding off.
The computer screen had gone black
and as I tried to move the mouse
to begin working again, I
noticed that lately the tremors
on my right side had worsened and
that my fingers wouldn't comply.
It snowed.
The blinding whiteness
stunned my eyes
and the cold made me walk
awkwardly with very short steps.
I remembered having been in that
same place during my childhood
and that the snow blinded me
while other children would call
out for me to catch up with them.
Suddenly, it surprised me that
it snowed for the first time.
As I opened my eyes, I saw the
transparent mountains and closer
yet endlessly red flowers
emerging from the snow
as if they were bloody entrails.
My fingers ran, letting
themselves go on the keyboard.
I understood your movies!
I still managed to
cry out to Kurosawa.
I understood your scripts!
There's snow.
There's a man with Parkinson's
that just fell in the snow.
>> Raúl Zurita: ¿Eras tú papá?
Después de cinco días esperando
que se despejara la neblina sobre la
costa norte pude ver
los acantilados.
Kilómetros y kilómetros de paredes
de granito cortándose a pique y mil
metros más abajo el Pacífico.
Había imaginado unas frases
escritas sobre esos murallones,
veintidós exactamente, de amor,
de locura y de muerte
recortándose sobre ellos.
Me las imaginé en un sueño.
La llanura del desierto de Atacama
que se interrumpía de golpe,
luego el abismo y al fondo el mar.
Años después morí.
Eran millones y millones de
hombres y mujeres arrojándose,
muchedumbres inacabables que se
detenían por un instante en el
borde de los paredones
y luego se lanzaban.
Algunos lo hacían
tomados de la mano,
se miraban a los ojos y
daban el último paso,
otros sostenían niños
en sus brazos,
algunos lloraban quedamente mientras
el viento del desierto hacía
flamear sus ropas.
Sentí un brazo posarse en
mi hombro, ¿eras tú papá?
y el vacío se abrió bajo
mis pies sin estruendo,
igual que una boca muda y dulce.
Al frente, el azul del inmenso
amanecer se iba fundiendo con el
Pacífico y las frases de
amor, de locura y de muerte,
se me pegaron en los labios
también sin estruendo, suavemente,
como un último silencio.
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Was it you, papa?
After five days of waiting
for the fog to clear
over the northern coast,
I could see the cliffs.
Kilometers upon kilometers
of jagging granite walls
and a thousand years
below the Pacific.
I had imagined lines written upon
those massive walls, exactly 22,
of love, of madness, and
death incising into them.
I imagine them in a dream.
The plain of the desert of
Atacama suddenly interrupted,
then the abyss, and then
to the bottom of the sea.
I died years later.
They were millions upon millions of
women and men throwing themselves.
Interminable crowds of people had
held back for a moment at the edge
of the vast walls and
then cast themselves down.
Some did it holding hands.
They looked into one another's
eyes and took the last step.
Others held children in their arms
and cried steadily while the desert
wind flailed their clothes about.
I felt an armrest on my shoulder.
Was it you, papa?
And the emptiness opened
beneath my feet without a sound,
just like a sweet, mute mouth.
Before me, the blue of the immense
sunrise had merged with the Pacific
and the lines of love, of
madness, and death stuck
to my lips also without a sound.
Softly. Like an irrevocable silence.
Like this.
>> Raúl Zurita: Verás.
En [inaudible] en los
acantilados afrente el mar.
Verás un mar de piedras.
Verás margaritas en el mar.
Verás un Dios de hambre.
Verás el hambre.
Veras un país de sed.
Verás las cumbres.
Veras un mar de cumbres.
Veras ríos en fugas.
Verás amores en fuga.
Verás montañas en fuga.
Verás indelebles erratas.
Verás el alba.
Verás soldados al alba.
Verás auroras como sangre.
Verás borradas flores.
Verás flotas retirándose.
Verás la nieve del fin.
Verás ciudades de agua.
Verás cielos en fugas.
Veras un paraíso vacío.
Verás que se va.
Verás no ver.
Y lloraras.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: You will
see written upon the cliffs
over the sea.
You'll see a sea of stones.
You'll see daisies in the sea.
You'll see a god of hungry.
You'll see hunger.
You'll see a country of thirst.
You'll see peaks.
You'll see the sea of the peaks.
You'll see vanishing rivers.
You'll see loves fleeing.
You'll see mountains fleeing.
You'll see indelible misprints.
You'll see dawn.
You'll see soldiers at dawn.
You'll see auroras like blood.
You'll see flowers erased.
You'll see fleets withdraw.
You'll see snow at the end.
You'll see cities of water.
You'll see skies fleeing.
You'll see an empty paradise.
You'll see it leave.
You'll see not seeing,
and you will weep.
So I'll read this first so
that you can hear Raúl last.
From Song for His Disappeared Love.
So Zurita, he came at me, now
that all verse and heartbreak,
you made it in here,
into our nightmares.
Can you tell me where's my son?
For the paisa.
For the Mothers of
the Plaza de Mayo.
For the collective of family members
of the ones who can't be found.
For all those tortured
doves of love,
Chilean countries, and assassins.
The Song for His Disappeared Love.
I sang. I sang about
love with my face soaked.
I sang about love and the
boys they smiled at me.
I sang harder, with passion,
the dream, and tears.
I sang the song about the
old concrete warehouses,
one on top of the other, they're
filled with dozens of niches.
In each, there's a country.
Like children, they're dead.
They all lay there, black
countries, African and wetbacks.
I sang this to them about
love, sorrow to the countries.
Thousands of crosses fill the
countryside, all for enamored women.
This is how I sang.
I sang love.
It was agony, the beatings,
and we broke into pieces.
I managed to hear you,
but the light was fading.
I search for you among the ruined.
I spoke with you.
What was left of you
saw me and I held you.
It all ended.
Nothing's left.
But Dad, I love you and we love
one another even though no one
can understand.
Yes, yes, thousands of
crosses fill the countryside.
I got here from all over the
place with a shitload of beer
in me, dying to relieve myself.
That's how I got here to
the old concrete warehouses.
Up close, they were rectangular
camps with broken windows
and the smell of piss, semen,
blood, and mucus reeked.
I saw messed up people.
Men blistered with smallpox and
thousands of crosses in the cooler.
Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
Turning my legs for all
those wrought up men.
I begged. Everything has been
erased except the damned warehouses.
Rey, a pervert, wanted
to grab me by the waist,
but aymara I tried my guard's number
out in the grass and he ran off.
Then they blindfolded me.
I saw the Virgin.
I saw Jesus.
I saw mother whipping off my skin.
I looked for you in the dark,
but pretty boys can't see
anything under the blindfold.
I saw the Virgin.
I saw Satan and Mr.
K. Everything was dry
in front of the concrete niches.
The lieutenant said let's go,
but I am in search of
and cried for my boy.
Oh, my love.
Goddam, said the lieutenant.
Let's color a little.
My girl died.
My boy died.
They all disappeared,
deserts of love.
They dumped lime and stone on us.
For a second I was
afraid they'd hurt you.
Oh, love, when I felt
the first crash,
I got pushed up against
you a little more.
It was something.
Yes, for sure, it was something.
I felt the stones smashing you and
I thought you'd scream, but no.
Love, these are things that pass.
Our dead love doesn't end.
I collapsed at your side thinking I
was the one who threw myself down.
But the grass must be
growing, I imagine.
In truth, I like stones, I thought.
No, the grass.
I thought it was you and it was me,
that I even now was alive,
but I fell you, on you.
Something of your life
proved me wrong.
It was just for a moment because
then you folded over, too,
and love grew us like
the assassinations.
Oh, great glaciers, close in.
great glaciers ceilings
over our love.
Eh, raspy girl, my
lovely boy cried out.
The dinosaurs are waking up.
The helicopters come down and down.
Where the old warehouses are.
The real high walls with TV towers.
You could end up on those screens.
Oh, yes, my love.
I turn the dial when I'm dreaming
and there you are in
black and white.
I say that's the guy in my dreams.
It's the guy in my dream.
When I wake up, there are only
wounded people in a long yard
and scalps hanging from antennas.
Listen, my friends, I yelled out.
Those times have already gone.
They just laughed at me.
They marked the guys with the
bayonet blow and cut their hair.
You smoke pot?
You smoke neoprene?
What kind of shit you
smoke, dirty red?
But they're lovely.
Even with all that, I go on the rag
when I see them, wet
my bed, and smoke.
I fall in love with them, do
myself up, and paint my whole face.
Drenched in tears, I say hello,
but everyone today
dreams the dream of death.
Oh, yes, pretty boy.
Great glaciers come to take
away the remains of our love.
Great glaciers come to
swallow the niches of our love.
The niches are one in
front of the other.
Far off they look like blocks.
I saw everything while they were
hitting me hard, but I turned
and the guard couldn't hold me back.
Over there I got to know colors
and saw the true god yelling inside
the freezing concrete warehouses.
Howling inside the phantom
concrete warehouses.
Getting completely soaked in the
not-possible concrete warehouses.
Chilean ass, my mother put me down.
Your time will come, too.
I went all over the place and saw
my parents without even leaving.
They're like God.
But my parents don't know their
puppy girl is dying of love
and blows in the old warehouses.
They look for me now,
scared to death,
knocking us up with thick spit.
Together, young and
old, we will be broken.
Oh, my love will break.
The wetback generation sing folk,
dances rock, but they're all dying
with their eyes blindfolded
in the warehouse bowels.
In each niche, they are a country.
They are there with the
South American countries.
Great glaciers come to collect them.
White glaciers.
Yes, brother.
Ceiling over, they draw near.
My girl died.
My boy died.
They all disappeared.
Deserts of love.
Argentina, Uruguay, and
Chilean countries of the love
that is mine and disappeared.
Through stairs, you walk up
from one country to another.
On elevators, you go up, or on
airplanes of the love that's mine
that also descends, the
penumbras that sometimes ascends.
You and I went there.
There we went among the
niches, you and I who spoke.
Did you eat me up?
Because you Chilean were
hungry, did you eat me up?
Did you break your heart?
Flowers of the central country
changed and it was that I was dying.
From your side, I died,
and they put me
above like the argentine countries
and found above the Chilean ones.
They all go up one
on top of the other,
niches of the South
American warehouse.
And dead, they're called.
They died us, I say, of sorrow.
And they call out to another.
Oh, love broken, we fell.
And as I fell, I wept.
Looking at you, it
was blow after blow,
but the last ones weren't
necessary anymore.
We barely managed to drag
ourselves among the fallen bodies,
to stay together, to stay
one next to the other.
Loneliness isn't hard.
Nothing has happened and my dream
lifts up and falls like always,
like days, like the night.
All my love is here and here
it stays, bound to the rocks,
the sea, and the mountains.
Bound. Bound to the rocks,
I went all over.
My friends sobbed inside
the old concrete warehouses.
The boys howled, come on.
We got to where they said,
I yelled to my pretty boy.
My face dripping, the
gentleman came with me,
but I couldn't find
anyone to say hello to.
Only some witches with their mouths
are ordering a real bloody one
for me.
I said you're crazy and
they said don't believe it.
Only the crosses could be seen
and the two old warehouses
covered by something.
From one bayonet blow,
they clipped my shoulder
and I felt my arm as
I fell to the grass.
With it, they beat my friends.
They went on and on, but when they
began to strike my parents I ran
to the urinal to throw up.
Immense prairies formed
with each heave,
the clouds breaking the sky
and the hills coming on.
What's your name and what
do you do, they asked me.
Look, he's got a tight ass.
What's your name, tight ass
bastard bitch, they said.
But my love is still bound to the
rocks, the sea, and the mountains.
But my love, I tell you, is
still stuck to the rocks,
the sea, and the mountains.
They don't know the
goddamn concrete warehouses.
They are them.
I come with my friends, sobbing.
I come from all over.
I smoke and hook up with the guys,
just some old-fashioned hook-up.
It's good for seeing colors.
I'm telling you, they
dig us out at our doors.
I'm telling you, they rip us apart.
Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
Of course, said the guard, you'll
have to yank it from its root.
My sliced up shoulder
bled and the blood stank.
If you turned around, you can see
the two huge warehouses where marks
of TNT, guards, and thick barbed
wire cover its broken glass.
But they will never find us because
our love is bound to the rocks,
to the sea, and the mountains.
Bound. Bound to the rocks, to
the sea, and the mountains.
My girl died.
My boy died.
They all disappeared.
Deserts of love.
>> Raúl Zurita: Canto
a Su Amor Desaparecido.
Ahora Zurita, me largo, ya que de
puro verso y desgarro pudiste entrar
aquí, en nuestras pesadillas.
¿Tú puedes decirme
donde esta mi hijo?
A la paisa.
A la Madres de la Plaza de Mayo.
A la agrupación de familiares
de los que no aparecen.
A toda la tortura, palomas del
amor, países chilenos y asesinos.
El canto a su amor desaparecido.
Cante, cante de amor, con la cara
todo bañado cante de amor y los
muchachos me sonrieron.
Mas fuerte cante, la pasión
puse, el sueno, la lagrima.
Cante la canción de los
viejos galpones de concreto.
Unos sobre otras decenas
de nichos los llenaban.
En cada uno hay un país, son
como niños, están muertos.
Todos yacen allí, países
negros, África y sudacas.
Yo les cante así de amor
la pena a los países.
Miles de cruces llenaban
hasta el fin el campo.
Entera su enamorada cante así.
Cante el amor.
Fue el tormento, los golpes
y en pedazos nos rompimos.
Yo alcance a oírte,
pero la luz se iba.
Te busque entre los
destrozados, hable contigo.
Tus restos me miraron
y yo te abrece.
No queda nada.
Pero muerta te amo y nos amamos,
aunque esto nadie pueda entenderlo.
Sí, sí miles de cruces
llenaban hasta el fin el campo.
Llegue desde los sitios
más lejanos,
con toneladas de cerveza
adentro y ganas de desaguar.
Así llegue a los viejos
galpones de concreto.
De cerca eran cuarteles
rectangulares,
con sus vidrios rotos
y olor a pichi,
semen, sangre y moco hendían.
Vi gente desgreñada,
hombres picoteados de viruela
y miles de cruces en la nevera,
oh sí, oh sí.
Todo se había borrado
menos los malditos galpones.
Rey un perverso de la
cintura quiso tomarme,
pero aymara el numero de mi
guardián puse sobre el pasto
y huyo.
Después me vendaron la vista.
Vi a la virgen, vi a Jesús, vi a
mi madre despellejándome a golpes.
En la oscuridad te busque, pero nada
pueden ver los chicos lindos bajo la
venda de los ojos.
Yo vi a la virgen, a
Satán y al señor K.
Todo estaba seco frente
a los nichos de concreto.
El teniente dijo vamos, pero yo
busco y llore por mi muchacho.
Ay amor. Maldición, dijo el
teniente, vamos a colorear un poco.
Murió mi chica.
Murió mi chico.
Desaparecieron todos.
Desiertos de amor.
Nos descargaron cal
y piedras encima.
Por un segundo temí
que te hicieron daño.
Ay amor, cuando sentí el primer
estrepito me pegue todavía un poco
más a ti.
Fue algo. Si, seguro fue algo.
Sentí las piedras aplastándote y
yo creí que gritarías, pero no.
El amor son las cosas que pasan.
Nuestro amor muerto no pasa.
Me derrumbe a tu lado creyendo
que era yo la que me arrojaba.
El pasto estará creciendo
me imagino.
En verdad me gustan más las
piedras creí, no, el pasto.
Creí que eras tú y era yo.
Que yo aun vivía, pero al
irme sobre ti algo de tu vida
me desmintió.
Fue solo un segundo, porque después
te doblaste tu también y el amor
nos creció como los asesinatos.
Ay, grandes glaciares se acercan,
grandes glaciares sobre
los techos de nuestro amor.
Eh ronca, grito mi lindo,
los dinosaurios se levantan.
Los helicópteros bajan y bajan.
Donde yacen los viejos galpones, las
paredes muy altas con torres de TV.
Tú podrías aparecer en
las pantallas, oh si amor.
En mis sueños enciendo el dial y
allí apareces en blanco y negro.
Digo ese es el chico que sonaba.
Ese es el chico que sonaba.
Cuando despierto solo hay heridos en
un largo patio y cueros cabelludos
colgando de las antenas.
Oigan amigos, les grite,
esas épocas ya pasaron.
Solo se rieron de mí.
Marcaron --
Marcaron a los muchachos y a
bayonetazos les cortaron el pelo.
¿Fumas marihuana?
¿Aspiras neopreno?
¿Qué mierda fumas rojo asqueroso?
Pero son lindos.
Aun así, yo me reglo de
verlos, mojo la cama y fumo.
Yo me enamoro de ellos, me
región y me pinto entera.
Envuelta en lagrimas los saludo,
pero todos sueñan hoy el sueno
de la muerte, oh si lindo chico.
Grandes glaciares vienen a llevarse
ahora los restos de nuestro amor.
Grandes glaciares vienen a
tragarse los nichos de nuestro amor.
Las nicherias están
una frente a la otra.
De lejos parecen bloques.
Todo lo vi mientras fuerte
me daban, pero me viré,
y mi guardián no pudo retenerme.
Allí conocí los colores y vi al
Verdadero Dios gritando dentro de
los helados galpones de concreto,
aullando dentro de los
fantasmas galpones de concreto,
mojándome entera dentro de los
imposibles galpones de concreto.
Mula chilena, me insultaba mi
madre, ya llegara también tu hora.
Me viré por muchos lugares y vi
a mis viejos sin salir de allí.
Son como Dios.
Pero ellos no saben que su cachorra
se está muriendo de amor y golpes
en los viejos galpones.
Ahora me buscan pobres
viejos ateridos.
Preñándonos de gruesos
escupitajos, juntos,
jóvenes y viejos reventaremos.
Ay amor reventaremos.
La generación sudaca
canta folk, baila rock,
pero todos se están muriendo con
la vista vendada en la barriga de
los galpones.
En cada nicho hay un
país, están allí,
son los países sudamericanos.
Grandes glaciares vienen
a recogerlos.
Blancos glaciares, si hermano,
sobre los techos se acercan.
Murió mi chica.
Murió mi chico.
Desaparecieron todos.
Desiertos de amor.
Argentina, Uruguay y los
países chilenos del amor mío
y desaparecido.
Por escalera se sube
de un país a otro.
Por ascensores se sube o por aviones
del amor mío que también baja las
penumbras y a veces sube.
Allí andamos yo y tú.
Allí andamos, entre los
nichos tú y yo que hablamos.
¿Me comiste?
¿Por qué tenías
hambre chileno me comiste?
¿No te apenaste?
Flores del Central país
cambiaron y era que yo me moría.
De tu lado me morí y me pusieron
arriba como los países argentinas
están ubicados sobre los chilenos.
Todos van subiendo unos sobre otros.
Nichos del galpón.
Sudamericano y muertos se llaman.
Nos murieron, te digo,
de la pena y se llaman.
Ay amor, quebrados caímos y
en la caída llore mirándote.
Fue golpe tras golpe, pero los
últimos ya no eran necesarios.
Apenas un poco nos arrastramos entre
los cuerpos derrumbados para quedar
juntos, para quedar
uno al lado del otro.
No es duro ni la soledad.
Nada ha sucedido y mi sueño
se levanta y cae como siempre.
Como los días.
Como la noche.
Todo mi amor esta aquí
y se ha quedado.
Pegado a las rocas al
mar y a las montanas.
Pegado, pegado a las rocas
al mar y a las montanas.
Recorrí muchas partes.
Mis amigos sollozaban dentro de
los viejos galpones de concreto.
Los muchachos aullaban.
Vamos, hemos llegado donde nos
decían, le grite a mi lindo chico.
Goteando de la cara me
acompañaban los señores.
Pero a nadie encontré
para decirles buenos días,
solo unos brujos con máuser
ordenándome una bien sangrienta.
Yo dije, están locos,
ellos dijeron, no lo creas.
Solo las cruces se veían y los dos
viejos galpones cubiertos de algo.
De un bayonetazo me cercenaron el
hombre y sentí mi brazo al caer
al pasto.
Y luego con el golpearon
a mis amigos.
Siguieron y siguieron, pero cuando
les empezaron a dar a mis padres
corrí al urinario a vomitar.
Inmensas praderas se formaban
en cada una de las arcadas,
las nubes rompiendo el cielo
y los cerros acercándose.
Cómo te llamas y que
haces me preguntaron.
Mira tiene un buen cul.
Cómo te llamas buen culo
bastarda chica, me preguntaron.
Pero mi amor ha quedado pegado en
las rocas, el mar y las montanas.
Pero mi amor te digo, ha
quedado adherido en las rocas,
el mar y las montanas.
Ellas no conocen los
malditos galpones de concreto.
Ellas son.
Yo vengo con mis amigos sollozando.
Yo vengo de muchos lugares.
Fumo y pongo con los chicos.
Solo un poco del Viejo pone y saca.
Es bueno para ver colores.
Pero nos están cavando
frente a las puertas.
Pero nos están rajando, te digo.
Oh sí lindo chico.
Claro, dijo el guardia, hay
que arrancarlo de raíz.
Oh, sí. Oh, sí.
El hombre cortado me sangraba
y era olor raro la sangre.
Dando vueltas se ven los
dos enormes galpones.
Marcas de TNT, guardias y gruesas
alambradas cubren sus vidrios rotos.
Pero a nosotros nunca nos hallaran
porque nuestro amor está pegado a
las rocas, al mar y a las montanas.
Pegado, pegado a las rocas,
al mar y a las montanas.
Murió mi chica.
Murió mi chico.
Desaparecieron todos.
Desiertos de amor.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: But listen.
If you don't come from a poor barrio
in Santiago, you won't get it.
You don't know shit
about what we live.
Look, there's no air.
It's going out of your fucking mind.
It's breaking into pieces for
barely a minute of happiness.
>> Raúl Zurita: Pero escucha.
Si tú no provienes de un barrio
pobre de Santiago es difícil que
me entiendas.
Tú no sabrías nada de
la vida que llevamos.
Mira es sin aliento.
Es la demencia.
Es hacerse pedazos por apenas
un minuto de felicidad.
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Es el final?
Ah, excelente.
[ Applause ]
¿Conversamos en inglés
o en español?
>> Anna Deeny Morales: En español.
>> Georgette Dorn: En español.
Una maravilla.
Precioso. [Inaudible] acá hace
como 30 años grabando para la
Biblioteca, verdad.
Es una gran - [inaudible].
Que rápido se van los anos.
>> Raúl Zurita: Fue año '90 o '89.
>> Georgette Dorn: '83.
[Crosstalk] Como pasa
el tiempo ¿verdad?
Pero es una maravilla.
>> Raúl Zurita: Muchas gracias.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Usted es muy muy bien.
[Inaudible] Y también quiero
felicitar a Anna por la
preciosa traducción.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Gracias.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y ahora me dice
que está traduciendo a Dante.
¿No es verdad?
>> Raúl Zurita: Estoy
traduciendo, sí.
Estoy traduciéndose.
Es verdad.
[Inaudible].
>> Georgette Dorn: Un gran
trabajo bastante difícil.
>> Raúl Zurita: Dificilísimo.
Demasiado.
Gran [inaudible].
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Cómo se
interesó por traducir a Dante?
>> Raúl Zurita: Mi abuela es
italiana, mi madre es italiana.
Entonces [inaudible].
La forma de [inaudible]
mi hermana [inaudible].
Pero de ahí [inaudible]
y creí [inaudible].
>> Georgette Dorn: Pues realmente
es una maravilla como usted.
La poesía que escribe es
muy - es fantástica, no,
se la manera que usted habla de las
montañas y del mar y del horror que
ha pasado a esto país, todos
países nuestros, verdad.
>> Raúl Zurita: Ojalá que
[inaudible] en el pasado en
el pasado.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Eso es precioso, sí.
Quiero preguntar a Anna como
es para traducir a Zurita.
Hace precioso, muy bien.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Gracias.
Bueno es como - es un gran placer,
pero también es como una
pasión a uno traduce.
Y crecí hablando en español y así
que creo que por lo menos para mí
como una persona bilingüe,
una persona latina,
para mí la traducción tiene
que ver con todo los idiomas que
convergen e interpretar y
representar como digamos la
violencia inherente y la existencia
de múltiples idiomas a la misma
vez, no, porque por lo menos
para mí como una persona mitad
puertorriqueña usa el español y
también para Raúl que es de Chile,
el español existe en América
debido a una violencia.
Así que imposible
cuando una representa,
cuando no traduce un idioma,
es imposible no representar esa
violencia inherente en la presencia
de los idiomas, no,
en ciertos lugares.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y es muy
importante para el poeta que se lo
traduzca bien para que si labra otro
idioma, otro país, otros lectores.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Sí y creo
que lo único que puede decir en
cuanta hay es que cuando uno traduce
no es esto lo que dijo esa persona.
Es más bien esto lo que
yo escuche decir eso.
Eso lo que yo escuche.
Así que yo le voy a representar
lo que yo escuche esa otra
persona diciendo.
>> Georgette Dorn: Así que
es una maravilla tenerlo acá.
Muchas gracias a todos.
Muchas gracias.
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Gracias, Georgette.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible background noise ]
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Preguntas?
Ah, bueno.
>> So we're going - if
anyone has a question -
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Hay
un micrófono para que la
gente pregunte?
>> Great opportunity.
>> Estoy interesado en el
proceso de traducción.
¿Cómo colaborar ustedes?
Como han trabajado para poder
traducir todos los libros en inglés
y cuál es la misión que
ustedes tienen de la traducción.
[Inaudible]
>> Raúl Zurita: Bueno, para mí
trabajar con Anna ha sido realmente
increíble porque [inaudible].
Entonces fue ha sido un placer.
[Inaudible] Es un proceso
bastante fascinante.
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Para mí también asido un
proceso fascinante.
Creo que más para
mí que para Raúl,
pero creo que lo más lindo es
que uno se conoce atreves de la
colaboración sobre los textos.
O sea la conversación en personal
vinieron después pero uno se conoce
ahí en el diálogo que
existe en los textos, no.
Pero o sea por una parte como
te interesa la traducción,
yo creo que por una parte es
importante reconocer todo lo que
quiere decir una palabra o una
frase en ese idioma dentro dese
contexto particular.
Pero otra parte cuando ese idioma
entra a otro idioma que en este caso
sería un inglés de los Estados
Unidos traducido por una persona que
creció hablando el español,
uno tiene que también dejar ir
ese primer idioma y hacer sonar los
idiomas que existen adentro del
propio idioma, adentro de inglés.
O sea cuando uno habla inglés
ahora en los Estados Unidos,
particularmente en lugar
como Washington, D.C.,
no puede negar que el
español está ahí, no.
Así que o también el inglés
esta en alemán presente.
Y por ejemplo uno no tiene que ir -
digo eso porque uno no tiene que ir
necesariamente por la dirección de
encónate, no.
Pues también hacer sonar los
idiomas de alemán en el inglés.
Y abrir todo ese campo, ese rango de
mundo alemán que existe adentro de
otro idioma.
O regresando el español usar
o número de silabas que existe
adentro de la traducción hispana
usando palabras en inglés.
Y así suena en la traducción
española en el inglés, no.
Así que por una parte tiene que
estar muy consiente lo que quiere
decir una palabra adentro
de ese contexto particular.
Por otra parte cuando entra el
inglés tiene que abrir eso.
O sea no tiene que
necesariamente cerrar la posibilidad
de significados.
También puede abrir hace
otras direcciones, no.
Que tiene que ver con ese
idioma la cual está trabajando.
Pero aparte de eso es uno ama al
poema y uno ama a esa persona, no.
O sea cualquier persona
que traduces.
Un gran amor que uno lleva en
cualquier momento y en la cual está
escuchando de otra persona y está
tratando de representar eso hay un
gran amor, no.
>> Georgette Dorn: Bueno,
pues, muchas gracias.
Micrófono.
Mucha gracia por venir y
mucha gracia a Maestro Zurita.
>> Raúl Zurita: Gracias a ustedes.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y a Anna.
Adiós. Muchas gracias.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.